question 523 de Madame marie-hélèine
desego transmise à Monsieur le Ministre
chargé des anciens combattants merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues j'ai souhaité attirer
l'attention de Monsieur le Ministre de
la Défense sur la différence de
traitement existant entre les engagés
volontaires des guerres mondiales des
guerres d'Indochine de Corée d'Afrique
du Nord et se servant actuellement dans
nos armées depuis la suspension de la
conscription en octobre
1997 seuls des volontaires servent
maintenant dans nos armées une partie de
ceux-ci sont des contractuels qui venant
de la société civile signe un contrat à
durée déterminée pour une armée ou une
formation rattachée au terme de ce
contrat d'engager ils peuvent être
désignés pour servir sur tout le
territoire où des troupes françaises
sont stationné ou seraient envoyé il
n'en demeure pas moins des volontaires
si pendant ce contrat initial a après
avoir servi à unité combattante ils
obtiennent la médaille commémorative
avec agraf ou la médaille d'outrem avec
agraf et la carte du combattant ils
remplissent alors toutes les conditions
cumulatives pour pouvoir prétendre à la
croix du combattant volontaire créé par
la loi du 4 juillet 1935 et attribué
depuis à toutes les générations du feu
cette décoration symbolique sans aucun
coûte pour l'État récompense l'acte de
volontariat initial de s engagés
volontaires qui ont accepté de leur
plein gré de mettre leur intégrité
physique et éventuellement leur vie au
service de la nation je vous demande
donc si au nom de l'équité et de la
reconnaissance que mérit ces volontaires
le gouvernement envisage d'attribuer la
croix du combattant volontaire avec
agrap mission extérieure aux engagés
volontaires venant directement de la
société civile et remplissant les
conditions habituelles je vous remercie
merci merci la parole est à Monsieur
Cader Harif ministre chargé des anciens
combattants monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice la Croix du
Combattant a volontaire a été créé lors
du premier conflit mondial et on est
justement dans ce cycle mémoriel pour
récompenser les combattants volontaires
et en servi au front dans unité
combattante alors que en raison de leur
âge il n'était astreint à aucune
obligation de service le droit cette
décoration a été étendue par la suite
par la création des barrettes
spécifiques à la guerre 3945 et au
conflit d'indochchine vous venez le
rappeler de Corée et d'Afrique du Nord
quatre conditions sont aujourd'hui
cumulatives sont exigées pour son
attribution avoir souscrit un engagement
sans laastreinte à une obligation de
service avoir été affecté en unité
combattante et être titulaire à la fois
de la carte du combattant et de la
médaille commémorative afférente au
conflit donnés les conditions
d'obtention de cette distinction ont par
ailleurs été étendu par deux fois au
cours des dernières années le décret du
9 mai 2007 a en effet
ouvert a ouvert aux appelés qui sont
portés volontaires pour CIP à une ou
plusieurs opérations extérieures
répertorié dans l'arrêté du 12 janvier
94 modifié fixant la liste des
opérations ouvrant droit au bénéfice de
la carte du combattant cette extension a
été réalisée pour reconnaître le
volontariat caractérisé des appelés de
la ce qu'on appelle la 4e génération du
feu
de même le décret du 22 décembre 2011 a
étendu au réservistes opérationnel dans
les mêmes conditions que pour les
appeler le bénéfice de la CCV avec
Barret mission extérieure mais madame la
sénatrice il en va différemment des
engagés volontaires qui sont des
contractuels de l'armée de terre de la
Marine nationale et de l'armée de l'air
et dont le statut est tout autre en
effet conformément à l'article
l4132-6 du Code de la défense ces
derniers sigent un contrat au titre re
d'une formation pour servir en tout
temps en tout lieu et en toutes
circonstances ils ne peuvent donc se
prévaloir d'un volontariat pour
participer à une opération dans le cadre
d'une mission extérieure car il s'agit
pour eux d'accomplir leurs devoirs en
vertu et dans le respect de leurs
contrats leur situation n'est d'ailleurs
pas différente de celle des autres
militaires recrutés selon d'autres
modalités en effet les uns comme les
autres ont exprimé à un moment ou un
autre leur volontariat pour le métier
des armes que cela soit en état candidat
à un concours d'accès à l'une des
grandes écoles de formation militaire ou
en postulant pour un recrutement par
contrat en revanche leur situation n'est
en rien comparable avec celle qui
aujourd'hui ouvre droit à cette
décoration dans ce contexte madame les
sénatrice l'extension du droit à la CCV
avec barrette mission extérieure au
profit des militaires contractuels
aurait pour effet d'introduire une
rupture de l'égalité de traitement entre
les différentes générations d'anciens
combattants toutefois il convient de
souligner parce que estce que c'est
possible que les intéressés sont
éligibles à toutes les distinctions et
récompenses auquelles peuvent prétendre
les militaires de carrière sous réserve
bien sûr de réunir les conditions
d'attribution
requises merci Monsieur le Ministre
madame
desego monsieur le Président je ne
souhaitais pas réagir mais bon écoutez
la définition du volontariat est un peu
particulière monsieur le ministre dans
votre dans votre bouche ce matin je
dirais que
certains militaires apprécieront ou
n'apprécieront pas votre votre réaction
votre réponse moi je regrette hein je
pense que nous reviendrons à la charge
sur cette question parce que c'est une
une question qui est récurrente qui est
importante et et je pense que c'est un
mauvais traitement qui est fait ce matin
voilà je le regrette merci
question